hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to
dr umar i'm going to be reacting to a
quick
clip titled dr umar is totally against
interracial marriage this is really
interesting because i'm in an
interracial relationship
right now so like
obviously like i have different opinions
but it's gonna be interesting to see
like what
what someone who's against interracial
relationships would say
before i start do not forget to
subscribe
for real guys you already know i'm
trying to move out of my parents house
at some point okay not that i really
like it here but like
um please subscribe okay
let me switch this
make it full screen and let me know in
the comments how my mic
quality is because i've gotten like
mixed oh what is this
mixed like reviews on my mic so let me
know if this like sound level is okay
dr uma are you totally against
interracial relationships
i am totally against it and i want to
make sure you understand
why it's not because cut it out
cut it out don't do that
because i won't have a name for it okay
no bunny crisis okay
i feel personally attacked it's the snow
bunny crisis
my boyfriend calls me a snow bunny all
the time
i feel attacked your white listeners to
understand
because people be trying to say stuff
like uh he's the black hitler
i'm not the black hitler i am i am in no
way interested in hurting or harming the
life of any human
white asian chinese i believe in
respecting everybody
the reason i'm against interracial
marriage envy and charlemagne
is because marriage is an economic
contract it's an economic contract
most women do not marry down in status
they marry up and if you don't believe
me
show me a rich white woman married to a
broke-ass black man
have you ever seen a rich white woman
marry a broke-ass black man
no you have not and you never will
because marriage ain't about love
it's not colorblind and it is totally
economic
so if marriage is an economic
unification and a contract
how can we who don't have enough already
give so much to the white woman
into white people who have already taken
too much when we got all these black
women out here who will never get
married
okay couple things a couple
what why are they calling black people
broke like
yeah some black people don't have money
but like there's rich
black guys too second off i just like
okay people that have takes like this
this is what i don't get
i do not care what other people do if
you're not my immediate family
if you're not a close friend you could
marry or date whoever the hell you want
it's not my business
so i i might say like this is something
that happened to me
based on my personal experience this is
the advice i would give whether you take
it or not
i don't care so like i don't know why
he cares what other people date like if
you date someone that
makes you happy who cares second thing
an economic contract i would guess that
the economic like the economic contract
piece
is more because people raised in similar
environments have similar values
and things that are important to them
i.e like
you know church um you know
decisions about money you know and so
forth
only one out of every four black women
in america
will ever taste marriage and half of
them who taste marriage will be divorced
within five years
if you want to save the black family if
you want to save the black family
you have to protect it and in order to
protect it you have to be against
interracial marriage you can't say
i love the black family but i don't have
a problem with interracial marriage
interracial marriage is eliminating the
black family because it is not providing
our women
with enough uh available enable black
men to be their husbands so you're
really
it's not just white women you just feel
white women asian
everybody nobody should be marrying out
the race because this political
consequence is dj envy i'll give you one
right now
naomi osaka am i saying her name right
the tennis system naomi osaka
naomi i love the sister right she
knocked off the greatest of all time the
goat
in selena but guess what who is she
representing in the upcoming olympics
is she representing haiti no she
representing japan
so here you have a half african sister
excuse me an
african sister will because there's no
such thing as half african our genes are
dominant so you got an african sister
with a japanese mother
and instead of going back home to your
father's blood haiti to represent the
africans in haiti
you're instead going to represent the
japanese who've never done anything for
black folks
and are part of the trilateral
commission with the american white power
structure
but who taught her to play tennis did
her japanese mother teach her to play
tennis
or did a black haitian father teach her
to play tennis her black haitian father
taught her to play tennis it's the
african dna it's the african ancestors
in that girl
that's responsible for her tennis
success but instead of representing us
she's gonna go represent the japanese
i see like it's the same thing who cares
look i'm irish and like german i'm like
all the white countries combined
but like i'm pretty sure i have like a
semi
like not like distant grandparent
um that is literally like from germany
but i literally do not care who
represents america and who represents
germany like
i just live my life man this is what you
got to deal with
when you make mixed-race african
children
i think her case is a little different
though because she identifies fully as a
black woman
she definitely does if you identify
fully as a black woman charlemagne why
she not representing haiti i get it but
that's a little asterisk because if she
she know cause she's putting her money
in the black cause she puts her money
into black organizations she got a black
boyfriend
like she she and she and she stands up
she stands up for black cause what
maybe there's more opportunity in japan
like again
who cares what other people do focus on
you
my the people that tell other people
what to do
are the worst kind of people i swear to
god and there's a difference between
saying like like advice channels like
i'll give people advice
but telling somebody that it's wrong to
marry outside of their race
or like you're gonna you're gonna tell
a girl that you don't know
that she should be representing haiti
when you have
no idea what opportunities are in haiti
and what opportunities
are in japan you have no idea you have
no idea why she made that decision
and like maybe if you had that
information it would make sense but what
i've learned in life is that
people in general make the best
decisions for themselves
like nobody can make decisions better
for you than yourself because you have
the most to gain and the most to lose
i don't know to be honest with you they
don't have to have one she will win the
whole thing but here's the point
if you look at the political situation
that america and france has haiti in
that they've been in since the haitian
revolution of 1791.
if you look at the fact that the
children are being raped robbed stolen
by whites
if you look at the fact that america and
france have sabotaged the haitian
economy in the haitian society if naomi
was to represent haiti one time
she can go back and represent japan next
time but if she was to represent haiti
just one time
it would shine a light on all the
injustices that the us government and
the french government are inflicting
upon brothers and sisters in haiti
and it will demand from the
international community
some answers and some changes she has a
chance
to almost rescue an entire nation of
people
okay number one i'm not gonna lie to you
guys i have no idea what he's talking
about
like i i don't know anything about haiti
i don't know what's going on in haiti
but what i do know is you cannot tell
what is she isn't she like
16 or like 18 she's like a young girl
that it's her
job to like fix the problems of an
entire country or shed light
onto the problems of an entire country
you're a grown-ass man
he probably based on like the way he's
talking he probably put
puts his money where his mouth is but
like
don't tell other people to change the
world go change it yourself
maybe that's what he's doing i don't let
me know in the comments if that's what
he's doing because i seriously don't
know i don't know who this guy is
she won't do it because she's not gonna
say that to the japanese blood that why
she not doing it brother i'm not i'm not
saying she hasn't to be honest with you
i'm sure she hasn't
cause she not representing haiti she
have not represented haiti but
but she speaks out against so many black
issues she probably has spoken on haiti
i don't know
charlemagne but i but i do see her speak
out a lot
in regards to the black people okay tell
him like
it's just like she probably does a lot
like it's i mean
again i don't know the situation but
like based on the way charlemagne's
talking
she probably does a lot for the black
community like
based on this just this conversation
alone and
this guy this other guy is coming in and
just saying like oh
you're not doing it the way i want you
to do it
i hate people like that but until she
speaks out for the haitians
and until she do something uh
significant for her father's
people until you do things she's a young
girl
chill dude until you do things the way i
want you to do them
who are responsible for the talent that
she got her father's people
her father who taught her how to play
tennis in the first place if it wasn't
for a haitian father charlemagne she
wouldn't be in that position
show love to haiti the point that i'm
trying to make look that up dan
i'm asking the white man oh yeah cause
i'm sure she i think i'm pretty sure
i've heard her speak out against that
but the point that i'm making
is if she represented haiti in the
olympics here's what i'm saying
charlotte i mean you can't take
a small soft act of activism
and try to use that to replace a major
significant act of activism
you're not doing things in the way i
want you to do them that's what he's
saying
look i don't have a problem with
activism i don't have a problem with
speaking out
but what i hate this is what i hate more
than anything
is people criticizing people
that are doing something but not in the
way that they want them to do it
if you want like you people seem to know
who you are
put your money where your mouth is dude
he probably does he probably does it
i've said this like a million times
but i just uh y'all you're gonna
criticize a young girl that
she's not doing enough when how old is
she what's her name naomi
you understand saying making one or two
news bites
during the context of a press conference
is not the same
as representing the republic of haiti on
the international stage
even if she says something i don't care
about that you had a chance
to represent the people who are
responsible for you being who you are
and you chose not to do it i'm not
knocking her
i'm a fan of her i want to be clear i'm
not knocking my sister
in fact i would probably have more
criticism for a father because i want to
know what you put in that little girl
that has a run into japan instead of
haiti
to represent them in the olympics here's
the point i'm making when you have mixed
race african children
these are the types of issues you're
going to have to deal with because until
african people get out of situations
that's why she has to play for them can
i ask you a question envy yes sir
if a white if a european jew is born in
africa
and he plays tennis is he going to
represent africa is he going to
represent israel
probably israel thank you so it ain't
got nothing to do with where you're born
it's where your loyalty is and until
black people get organized fellas
many of our mixed-race children are
going to identify with the other race
because they're doing better than we
well maybe maybe she'll hear this and
take take take what you're saying in
consideration well i'm not knocking her
i just want y'all to show
i just want y'all to see it does not
benefit the black community
to be having all these mixed-race babies
who are not loyal to us
i have nothing against mixed race
because you are fully african in my
opinion i was going to ask you that what
do you think
no problem with a mixed-race african i
judge all black people i don't care if
you from africa because i'm a
pan-africanist so it's all one family
for me
i don't care if you're in the caribbean
brazil europe
australia the continent canada two
things
two things are you biologically black
and are you psychologically black and
when i say psychologically black do you
identify with your primary race naomi
does you understand
so if you are psychological let me know
in the comments but that does not make
sense to be
are you psychologically black like
are all black people supposed to think a
certain way
because like what if i said am i
psychologically irish
i would have no idea what the hell or
psychologically german
let me know in the comments guys
logically black and you are biologically
black
i treat you no different i don't care if
you high yellow with green eyes or blue
black purple i don't get into this color
game
because i think part of the petty
differences we have as a people is we
over accentuate this light skin dark
skin nappy hair
straight hair thing too much and it's
killing us it's the blood
the first color on this flag is red for
a reason
it's the blood that makes you african so
i would never mistreat a mixed race
african but i'll tell you one thing i'ma
make sure they understand you will not
perpetuate the snow bunny crisis
just snope i feel attacked attacked
no unlike a lot of people
i really don't care um
i think you're going to have a hard time
in life if you try to tell
people how to live and how society
should be society
just is if black guys want to marry
white girls
they will there's nothing you can really
say or do about it
and honestly i don't really get why he
cares but
maybe you do so if you do let me know in
the comments
also do not forget to like comment and
subscribe i'm gonna talk to you guys
probably in like an hour to be honest
because i'm about to film another video